let's get you into your top five
headlines bro this is how we start
safety blitz every week your five
biggest takeaways leaving the sunday
leaving the monday leaving a football
weekend want to start with some
offensive lines you were impressed by
the ravens and the raiders how'd they
catch your eye
it just you know when you talk about
offensive lines they don't get enough
credit we always talk about the
quarterbacks and the star players and
the receivers and things like that but
you look at the ravens and what they
were able to do over 200 yards rushing
it was absolutely outstanding and the
guy that played um right tackle last
week that stunk alejandro villanuevo
he came and moved to the left side and
he had an outstanding game and that was
one of your concerns could he replace
ronnie stanley and you talk about the
raiders they lost their starting center
because he got traded they lost their
starting right guard because he got
traded they lost their starting right
tackle because they got traded and the
raiders offensive line has been
fantastic and that's a big part of why
derek carr is having success because
he's back there once again behind that
cushy offensive line and not getting a
lot of pressure put on
i don't think anything was more
impressive we're going to get into the
raiders the raiders deserve some serious
love and we will get into all that i
want to hit this ravens offensive line
real quick though cause you think about
the 98 million dollars that they are
paying ronnie stanley they gave him all
that money about 48 hours before he had
a devastating injury to his leg and so
now you look at this offensive line
alejandro villanueva goes over to left
tackle and it's really the spot where
he's more comfortable but to see him
instantly click in and just go play i
mean there was two horrible early inter
interceptions in this game that lamar
jackson threw boatswain to the honey
badger to tyron matthew but the way the
offensive line in this run game in red
zone lamar jackson worked their way back
look how great he is in the red zone i
mean people just can't they can't get a
hand on him you get him out there in
space he's gonna figure out a way to get
it across the pylon and he did time and
time again one more time i love
everything but the flip it made for a
good instagram post i got that but
lamar's taking enough hits as it is i
don't need any somersaults this
offensive line took over the game and
now i think from what i've been hearing
some whispers of they may take ronnie
stanley with the ankle injury that he
has move him over to right tackle keep
villanueva where he's comfortable with
left tackle and have two great book in
tackles on the field at the same time
what would you think of that strategy
give him the opportunity to plant off
his healthy ankle over at right tackle
for ronnie stanley could be a dangerous
combination for the ravens
and brother let me tell you something i
i right after the game i got a chance to
talk to coach harbaugh just hanging out
after the game in a tunnel for about 20
minutes and that was something that i
thought about mentioning it to him but i
didn't want to have him give me all the
secrets but yeah i think that's
absolutely spot on because you still get
the quality and the experience of ronnie
stanley but you get him on the other
side where he doesn't have to worry
about the the best pass rusher every
single week so i think it's a great way
of keeping him engaged and allowing him
to still stay connected to the team and
playing and being a productive player
let's get you to your second headline
here rod early mvps you gave us three of
them i want to throw these back your way
brady carr and tyler murray why are you
high on these guys right now who's
catching that eye
man come on man i mean these dudes are
getting it done car obviously car cars
always complaining i don't get enough
respect i don't get enough respect
you're not going to get a lot of respect
when you check the ball down but when
you start humping that thing down the
field you're going to get all the
respect in the world and he has the
talent there
he he has darren waller he has
hunter renfro a guy that's been very
very consistent for him i mean he's got
some speed on the outside i like tom
brady five touch was it five touchdowns
that he threw last week was it four or
five touchdowns
and calip and colin murray was
absolutely outstanding he's
single-handedly willingness offense and
willing this team to victory so those
are my three early ones what are your
thoughts
car blew me away
more than anything i i watched that
whole game all the way through and i'm
going how how did they go beat the
steelers i think first and foremost big
ben sort of started to look like a bit
of a shell of himself he just
athletically he used to be able to
create a first and a second or third
play and he can't really do that anymore
but carr was just so on the money i mean
if you go watch every play of this game
the number one thing that will stand out
look at this this is a third long third
and ten henry cutting up a rug right
down the middle of the defense for a
post running by everybody and carr
couldn't have put that ball and he was
perfectly under pressure if he tried
please rob what'd you see
hey and and then you see the safety who
was on the ground
that was mika fitzpatrick so not only
did he beat the corner but he beat one
of the top middle of the field safeties
i'm talking about a guy that is out
absolutely outstanding you know whether
he's playing nickelback whether he's
playing in the deep middle the car
through that where only the receiver
could go get it he let him it was
absolutely unbelievable what he was able
to do and then think about last week
what he did against um the ravens he
attacked their 90 million dollar
cornerback marlon humphrey he went right
at him with their fourth wide receiver
so it just shows you not only does he
have confidence but he has confidence in
all of his players and it's just really
nice to see that derek carr is starting
to get some love because before i was
just calling them check down charlie
and brian edwards looks like a great
wide receiver too i don't know if you've
been seeing edwards this is back to back
weeks you should have had another
touchdown in this game i thought it was
an awesome play design too
they sort of i mean honestly if you go
re-watch the first half of the game the
raiders should have been up 21 to seven
they played so badly once they would get
down around the red area whether it was
like a false start a drop snap penalty
on the down you know throw a touchdown
there's a penalty edwards that touchdown
had to come back so they were making
mistake after mistake after mistake kept
having to settle for field goals instead
of what should have been touchdowns but
when you think about brian edwards and
renfroe and waller another tight end and
monroe they've been getting the ball to
ruggs going with the deep threat talk
about josh jacobs who was hurt in this
game they went into pittsburgh and
knocked off the steelers after they had
just beat the bills without josh jacobs
one of their best players on that
offense i don't know what this team
doesn't have that's what i left this
game thinking i think the raiders are a
playoff team at least and i think they
might be dangerous once they get in
there what do you think about that rod
that those were my thoughts why they
don't came back
dude i'm pumped up because and and it's
not necessarily for the offense that i'm
really loving the raiders i'm really
loving their defense and it's not a lot
of big names anything like that but guys
max crosby
and that leads me to my third takeaway
max crosby is a defensive player of the
year right now he's been absolutely
outstanding and i know everybody gauges
stuff on saks i think he has a couple
sacks but he's leading the league and
like um quarterback hits pressures i
mean he's all over the place and even
more importantly than that the fact that
this guy's playing with so much energy
and he's he's getting all these other
players flying around i mean when you
watch the raiders play this guy is just
a psycho out there going crazy and guess
what now you got abram coming now you
got kj wright you got all these other
guys combining and the raiders are
flying around believing in themselves
they're playing physical they're
stopping to run
hey john gruden you got to give him some
props man he's got this team right where
he wants him and this is what year four
of his regime right now i think it is
and they're they're playing so hard for
them you're drilling the points right
there they're just playing hard playing
championship football for grunting is
what they're doing i mean we just went
off on the offense now you're starting
to mention some of these defenders and
gawkway he's been tough casey hayward jr
he's been awesome on the back end you
mentioned max crosby awesome 19 total
pressures he had the next closest on the
team he had 19 talking about crosby you
just mentioned next closest is nine
within gawkway so he is just pulling
away from everybody eight quarterback
hits for cosby next close on the team is
two nine quarterback hurries that leads
the team too so you mentioned that he's
a lesser name right now may be true with
crosby but he may be looking for one of
those big money paydays and he's earning
it right now rod what do you think they
may have to pay this guy eventually
hey obviously i love the kid and the
young man if i'm sitting here saying
he's the defensive player of the year
right now you still you know tj watt had
a two or three sacks and you get still
got aaron donald and some other guys out
there yeah but this kid he's bringing
that energy every sin and look we fell
in love with him last year but the
raiders lost a lot of close ones and now
this year they're winning now he's
starting to get the props that he
deserves and and let me tell you when
you're a great defensive player and you
play hard and you play with a lot of
energy other guys want a piece of that
other guys want to follow you and that's
exactly what i see him from a leadership
standpoint
carl nasim has been very tough too he's
long over there he can really get those
offensive linemen off them and he brings
some thunder too when he hits you carl
nasa want to give him a little bit of
love let's get to lamar jackson lamar
bringing this team back i mean we're
sitting there we have this great trailer
rodney we have this like home on the
road we live on the road so they brought
this home out there for us we got all
these tvs we can watch the game all
these different angles and everything
it's like it's my favorite day of the
week hanging out with you watching
football and lamar throws these two
early interceptions and brings this team
all the way back just describe for me
this performance this lamar jackson
performances he's looking for 200
million plus to go beat my homes what'd
you see
brother if i if i were the baltimore
ravens i would have took him in a small
room and said let's hammer out this
contract because the more you wait on
lamar the more it's going to cost you i
mean for this guy and to show the level
of mental toughness and the maturity
to overcome those two interceptions and
then not only two interceptions but a
pick six normally when you see an
average a quarterback with an average
mindset he's done after two
interceptions let alone uh two
interceptions and a pick six
and this guy he just kept fighting kept
clawing and that just shows you to make
up to the team props out to coach
harbaugh he is that dude keeping these
guys engaged keeping them together and
and when even when we talk to hollywood
brown we we talked to him about coach
harbaugh and he was like yeah man that
that guy deserves a lot of the credit
because he keeps us together but lamar
man the mental toughness the physical
toughness the love that he got from his
teammates and then you got the head
coach asking you this is how much they
think of lamar the head coach is asking
lamar do you want to go for it i
absolutely love that i will never ever
forget that moment in my life
let me look at it he's asking this is a
coach has won a super bowl coach that's
been highly successful a well-respected
coach one of the top five coaches in the
national football league he's asking
this quarterback do you want to go for
it that's how much belief that he has in
lamar that's the type of belief that he
has in his team so props out to coach
harbaugh props out to lamar lamar you
are everything lamar lamar lamar man
it's going to be hard to bet against you
again bro
you said that so well i almost just want
to move on to another topic i mean you
just hit everything i want to hit but i
kind of just want to emphasize a bit of
it i loved hollywood brown as well at
the very end of the game when we were
talking to him on the field we had the
marching band behind us it's like a
college football atmosphere there in
baltimore yeah the marching band i mean
it's like we're doing the pre-game show
rod and they got a full about 100 person
deep marching band just marched into the
stadium i never seen anything like it
there's like 300 people around our set
going nuts they got their faces painted
this is a football town there in
baltimore when hollywood brown said i
take moments throughout a game when
lamar like that perfect deep ball he put
on he said i pull them aside whether
it's halftime over on the sideline i
tell them you are one of the truly great
quarterbacks not only playing right now
that has ever played this game you do it
your way you play it with your style and
he takes moments right now he said i
don't want to wait till he's gone i
don't want to wait till his career is
over i want to tell lamar jackson right
now how great he is that friendship
between wide receiver and star
quarterback it's pretty awesome to watch
over 100 yards and a touchdown for
hollywood brown too
hey brother let me tell you something
and that's why i'm i'm enjoying so much
being on a road with you because we get
a chance i mean we're football fans
first and foremost we're football fans
and we get a chance to get on that field
and be 10 15 yards away from seeing
lamar jackson patrick mahomes tyron
matthew all these superstars in the
national football league so we're out
there like kids in a candy store we get
a chance to interview these guys but to
see what what these guys get to do up
close and personal man it's just a
different level of quarterback and look
when i saw um michael vick and played
against michael vick i'm like oh my god
and
that's lamar jackson plus patrick
mahomes like
it's just incredible to be able to see
and be able to witness what we see every
single week props out to lamar you made
it dog on my top five um takeaways we
still got one more to go though 100
100 we got one more to go and i'm
thinking i'm always kind of going like
why is kansas city not selling out to
try to just stop this run game and i
think the answer is pretty simple
it's the same for the rest of the league
they can't they can't stop the run
there's so many different players going
so many different ways and the way
they're hitting them with these blocks
now lamar's running now the running
backs running out of the receivers
coming across for they just do so many
different things in this run game people
just can't stop it let's get you to your
number one take away hold on hold on
hold on hold on through
jack please please
and the one thing that we forgot to
mention think about their defense and
how they're built their defense is built
to play from ahead they're used to
having two and three touchdown leads so
now you get frank clark you get chris
jones you get all these pass rushers
they're able to pin their ears back and
get after the quarterback because now
instead of running the ball running the
ball if you're an opponent you got to
come out and you have to pass the ball
so this defense is kind of like the old
indianapolis coach that coach dungey
used to have they're built to play from
ahead because they're so used to playing
from ahead and that's why they can't
stop the run because they got these
small guys i mean they got some big guys
in there but they're just they're just
not run a run stop and team and that's
going to cost them come playoff time if
they don't get it corrected
um and they're gonna have to be dealing
with the raiders who we were just
talking about who looked pretty darn
good over there in the afc west as well
let's get you to your fifth takeaway
carson wentz injuries struggles continue
wins with a new team now are you
believing in who he is overall now that
he's an individual where are you leaning
with this no
i never believed in him i mean when he
was in even when he was in philly i
wasn't a big believer in him i just i
mean he's in a situation now you got
everything in front of you you have an
offensive line and how can a quarterback
make an offensive line look bad
he holds the ball too much he just sits
there and he holds the ball i'm sitting
there watching tape and all he has to do
is check it down and it's like he's so
afraid to just get rid of the ball
and it's amazing to me and like you got
quinton nelson blocking in front you got
all these good dudes getting paid a lot
of money and you got skilled players
you you got running backs that can catch
the ball out of the backfield and he's
hurt he can't complete passes down the
field he's inconsistent he looks
confused and i just think that frank
wright and everybody puts so much on
this guy he has so much pressure on
himself that
he's just he's just not a very good
player at this point in time and i i
just
this might be a disaster this year if he
can't get it corrected he got to get
himself healthy both physically and
mentally he has to be ready but he holds
on to the ball entirely too long jack
he does and that creates a lot of
problems now he has two sprained ankles
and athleticism is a big part of his
game even when he's throwing the ball
the ability to move around and create
those second launch points is a big part
of what he does two sprained ankles at
the same time pretty tough to be able to
go do everything that he wants to do i
mean you think about his career though
and he was during that super bowl year
playing essentially mvp level football i
mean kind of just putting the ball
wherever that year then he gets hurt
doesn't end up taking him all the way
through the championship game and now
it's kind of falling apart for personal
reasons up there with doug peterson they
didn't seem to be getting along you just
sort of saw it just pulling apart at the
seams now he goes to indy and he's
trying to recreate it now he's injured
we're not even out of september football
yet i'm not totally willing to dump on
everything that he is yet knowing that
he's banged up i want to see how the
rest of the season plays out but with
that offensive line with some of the
young weapons they have there in nd i'm
with you you want to see this thing
happen for him or i don't know where the
next stop on his train would be it's
just wild to me how fast this thing has
gone downhill for carson wentz
yeah they need to they need to commit to
running the football i don't know why
these these head coaches and these
offensive coordinators are so stuck on
trying to sling the rock around you got
that offensive line put jonathan taylor
a guy that runs a 4-3 and he's 230
pounds
look i was a physical safety and i don't
want to hit somebody that runs a 4 3 2
30 every single play like run the
football then you can set up the play
action pass the bootlegs and all the
different things the screens and the
dump offs to nahim heinz like they have
a really good defense but when you have
bad quarterback play it affects
everybody because now all of a sudden
your defense starts to press thinking
okay we have to create turnovers because
our offense can't score and it shouldn't
be like that man he's got everything set
up in front of him he's got offensive
line he's got weapons he's got tight
ends he's got a really good head coach
with all as an offensive coordinator if
he can't succeed here then he should be
out the league or he's going to be a
backup quarterback but he's got
everything at his disposal and he's
still not getting it done
now he's got all that and two sprained
ankles he may be at the top of the list
of guys who needs to turn the page just
turn that page it's turned the page
tuesday when we come back to the other
side's team looking for a little new
energy up next
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports